Homelander in space, a brutal Butcher murder,
and an extended Love Sausage scene are just
a few of The Boys Season 2's most twisted
deleted scenes.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing the original ending
to the second season plus seven more deleted
scenes you never got to see!
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
By the end of Season 2, Homelander finds himself
defeated on numerous fronts.
He's lost his son Ryan to Butcher, Stormfront
has been maimed and exposed as a Nazi, and
he's been blackmailed by Maeve into welcoming
Starlight back into the Seven.
So, by his final scene, he attempts to heal
his bruised ego on the New York rooftops repeating
to himself "I can do whatever I want".
However, The Boys showrunner Eric Kripke has
now revealed an alternate ending with Homelander
in space instead.
Speaking to The Wrap, Kripke said that originally
Homelander was "hovering over the earth, […] like
Superman does, but [he] had [...] a scary
sociopathic look."
According to Kripke, the scene was actually
filmed and was "awesome", but Amazon asked
"if [they] could stick the landing on [Homelander]
a little harder.
And […] have something that maybe [wasn't]
quite as ambiguous."
So, Kripke decided to go back to a Season
1 deleted scene of Homelander on the Chrysler
Building which interestingly Amazon had refused
to allow at the time,
and he submitted that as the new Season 2
ending.
Amazon preferred this recycled finale because,
as Kripke says,
"it's telling us something about how powerless
and pathetic [Homelander] feels in that moment
and how dangerous he'll be moving into Season
3."
I can see why they opted to change the ending,
but personally I think a really menacing scene
of Homelander in space looking down on Earth
would have been more interesting as it'd look
like he's threatening the whole world.
And it would have tied in stronger with the
idea that's been building in Season 2 that
Homelander could go completely off the rails
at any point.
For example, there was the moment where he
imagined himself massacring the crowd who
were booing him,
and there was the threat he made to Maeve
in the final episode if she released the video
of the airplane incident.
"If you do that..
..I'll destroy everything
and everyone."
After A-Train is ejected from the Seven, he
becomes desperate to get back in the team,
and there's a great deleted scene which sheds
a lot more light on his motivations to return
to the spotlight.
In the cut scene, A-Train visits his financial
adviser to discover that despite the fact
that he earns over 40 million a year, he has
less than a quarter of a million left.
"240 thousand dollars.
Nah, this.. this can't be right.
Run those numbers again."
"I have trust me, that's all you got."
"I make 40 million dollars a year."
The adviser goes on to list all the deductions
taken out of A-Train's income such as..
"..taxes.
There's also commissions from your agents,
your managers, your lawyers, me.
You've got two dozen people on your payroll,
and that's not counting friends and relatives."
And after A-Train tries to justify this by
claiming he has responsibilities, his adviser
notes all the speedster's crazy expenditures.
"13 houses, a private jet, an island that
you've never been to, and paying to have Jan
Michael Vincent's ashes shot into space.
And then he drops the even bigger bombshell
that A-Train doesn't even have the rights
to exploit his own brand.
"Get booted from the Seven, so f-ing what?
I still got this.
I'm still A-Train."
"Actually bruh, you're not.
You see, Vought owns the name, the uniform,
everything."
Basically, Vought can completely destroy him
financially if he attempts to use the name
in any commercial endeavour.
"I'm A-Train!
If I wanna open up A-Train's Cadillac or whatever
the f- I wanna do, that's exactly what I'm
gonna do."
"Not if you wanna get sued and lose all of
your money."
This is a really interesting scene that gives
some insight into exactly how much money Supes
can earn if they make it to the top tier of
talent,
and how ill-equipped they can be to deal with
the business side of their work, like many
other celebrities,
but it also shows just how expendable they
are if they fall out of favour.
Love Sausage is one of the – shall we say
– more intriguing Supes that the gang discover
when they break into Vought's secret psych
ward in the sixth episode.
And after the patients take over the asylum,
Mother's Milk suddenly finds himself attacked
by the Russian man's super-powered appendage
which begins to strangle him.
M.M. manages to remove the monstrous thing
after Kimiko knocks Love Sausage out with
her brass knuckles and it recedes back into
the unconscious Supe's pants.
As crazy as this scene is already, originally
it was going to be even crazier.
In an interview with TV Line, Tomer Capon
who plays Frenchie, revealed that Laz Alonso,
who plays Mother's Milk, had pitched an idea
to the episode's director that during the
fight,
while the giant genitalia was wrapped around
his neck, Frenchie should save him by biting
the prosthetic member off.
Capon agreed and the scene was filmed, however,
apparently the tentacle ended up torn to shreds
and the footage wasn't good enough to use.
And because only one prosthetic had been made,
they couldn't repeat the scene.
According to The Boys showrunner, Love Sausage's
massive appendage was a combination of a 10-foot
long animatronic puppet with extra CG effects
added in post-production.
Leave a thumbs-up if you like this deleted
scene and maybe one day the footage will get
released on a blooper reel!
There's a great Kimiko deleted scene from
the fourth episode where we get to see more
of how she tries to manage the emotional fall-out
from her brother's death at the hands of Stormfront.
It starts with her watching one of the secret
Nazi's rants on social media, but then she's
distracted by a rodent that's wandered into
her room.
She befriends the little creature by feeding
it some snacks, and then she hears the news
about Stormfront's upcoming protest.
[Stormfront] "Let's show Vought what they
have to do.
Tomorrow morning, Vought Square.
Be your own hero.
Do not let me down."
The scene fades and we find Kimiko pacing
nervously until she discovers the friendly
creature has died in a trap underneath her
bed.
The animal's death is particularly upsetting
because it reminds her of her murdered brother
Kenji, and the nickname "mouse" that she used
to call him.
If it looked like Kimiko was in two minds
over whether to confront Stormfront at the
rally, it seems like the rodent's death was
what ultimately led her to that decision.
"Kimiko, open the door please.
Kimiko!"
There's an interesting deleted scene from
the first episode in which we see Frenchie
argue with Cherie over the special relationship
he has with Kimiko.
"Okay, it's not like that, okay!"
"You wanna f- her, f- her.
Just spread the wealth."
"We are not..
..I would never sleep with her."
"Oh yeah, then what is she to you then?
I mean, I see the way you look at her."
"It's difficult, it's difficult to explain,
she's special."
Cherie doesn't buy what Frenchie is saying
and mocks him.
"So me, you can pull me by the hair and f-
me sideways, but her..
..she's too magic and special, huh?"
This scene helps to better set up the moment
later in Season 2 when Frenchie attempts to
kiss Kimiko.
Plus it adds more weight to the scene where
he confesses to Cherie that he tried it on
with her.
"You thought a kiss would make her feel better
or you feel better?"
When Billy Butcher turned up at the very end
of the Season 2 premiere, we didn't get any
proper explanation of where he'd been in between
the Season 1 finale and reuniting with the
Boys this season.
Originally a lengthy five-minute scene was
going to fill in the gaps, but it ended up
cut and released instead as a short film titled
"Butcher".
The original scene reveals that after Butcher
left Tony Cicero's, he steals a car and drives
to the house of an old SAS friend called Jock.
After reminiscing for a while about their
days in the field, Butcher asks Jock if he
can help him find his wife Becca.
"Thought maybe you could put some feelers
out you know?
Get some of the old intel boys, Higgins, Esquerra."
"All respect, yeah?
Doesn't seem to me like your girl wants to
be found."
"Look, are you going to f-ing help me or not?"
"Course I am, we're mates, aren't we?"
After re-emerging from the shower wearing
the tracksuit that Frenchie asked him about
in the first episode, Butcher discovers that
Jock has sold him out and called the authorities.
"Ordering pizza are we?"
"Take it easy mate.
Plodders are on their way."
"You shouldn't have done that Jock."
"You topped that Stillwell woman on the telly.
You gonna top your wife as well?"
"I didn't kill no one."
"Come on Billy, I seen what you can do.
You're a killer down to the ground.
That don't change."
The two fight, and Butcher, proving his friend
right in a way, chokes him to death and torches
the whole house.
I can see why this didn't make it into the
show because it's a side story that isn't
that crucial for the main plot and would have
slowed down an early episode had it been included.
It does show Butcher, as we've seen a few
other times, at his most ruthless and murderous.
Clearly his friend was betraying him without
asking Butcher whether any of the news stories
were really true,
but Butcher certainly didn't hold back on
finishing the guy off, when he could have
just incapacitated him.
There's a curious deleted scene from the third
episode with Stormfront and Maeve reacting
to the news leaks about Vought secretly administering
Compound V to babies.
"Did you know about this?"
"No.
But I mean are you really surprised?
Some a- stood up in a meeting and said we
could make a race of super-beings that we
can control, own and monetize.
All we have to do is inject a few babies."
It's a shame this scene was cut because it
helps give more reasons as to why Queen Maeve
changed her mind about helping Starlight in
the final episode.
When Maeve watched Stormfront stride past
her in the Tower as the details of her Nazi
past broke on the news,
she doubtless would have remembered the pretence
Stormfront made of not knowing anything about
Compound V in this deleted scene.
One of Stormfront's secrets is that she was
the first person who was successfully injected
with Compound V by her Nazi husband Frederick
Vought, something she was more than happy
to disclose to Homelander.
We know Mother's Milk is all about his family
and as a way of trying to keep himself in
balance while trapped in the Boys' underground
hideaway,
throughout the second season we see him constructing
a large dollhouse which he plans to give to
his daughter Janine.
And a scene cut from episode 4 would have
revealed what happened when he finally finished
it.
In the deleted scene, we see M.M. meticulously
dust and finish off the grand dollhouse,
but as he contemplates his achievement he
decides instead to offer it to someone else:
"Hey.
You got a little girl, don't you?"
"8 years old."
"Give her this.
It's all yours."
This would have been a nice character moment
for Mother's Milk as it shows him accepting
the reality of the situation that he can't
be with his family right now.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been included in Season 2?
And would you have preferred the original
ending of Homelander in space?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed any of these scenes, a
thumbs-up is hugely appreciated.
Next tap left to check out my full deleted
scenes and alternate endings playlist or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!